could amazon be about to announce a new
stargate series welcome to sidetrack
your sci-fi tv and movie channel
right i'm going to tell you straight off
the bat here this is based on a rumor
it's a rumor that i i'm not 100
convinced i believe but
it's it's out there so i'm going to tell
you guys this is what i was told so i
will tell you and i was told this from a
source that actually
works in and around amazon this time
instead of my usual sources of working
around mgm
um i can't tell you exactly how this
situation has occurred but it's
something i've spoken to before and they
do work with amazon
i should also say that the people i work
at mgm who i have
asked about this agree that this is a
distinct possibility
so what is the rumor well the rumor is
something that we heard a couple of
months ago actually that amazon were
hoping to announce a new stargate series
by the 25th anniversary of when sg-1
came out and that would be july 27th in
just a couple of months
but
we've been through a bit of a roller
coaster in the last two months with
stargate and it's gone from looking like
it was
so on the card about to be announced to
not looking so likely
so how is this rumor happened what is
what is going on
well
last week i told you that it looks like
there's a lot going on at mgm and it
looks like amazon are planning to
basically dismantle mgm that they only
bought mgm for the intellectual
properties they're not actually
interested in a lot of the actual
employees and the infrastructure mgm
currently has and it will simply be
absorbed into amazon film now that has
already pretty much been announced by
amazon executives um and it looks like
the process has already happened please
go back and check out my live video from
a few days ago
but what does this actually mean for
star game well one of the things i was
told a couple of weeks ago as well was
that amazon are already planning to do a
new tv series of the 2000 space odyssey
possibly also a tv series a mini series
based on the forbidden planet these are
two mgm intellectual properties but
they're not going to be produced by mgm
they're going to be produced within
amazon pictures
could stargate be about to go the same
way well according to my source yes
amazon pictures of absorbing stargate
and they are going to be doing the work
but what does this mean for the show
well
we know a lot of work has been done on
the new stargate series we know there's
been artwork preliminary artwork some
preliminary storyboarding four big
executive meetings that were back in
april we know brad wright has not just
written one script but two he wrote one
to three years ago after some pressure
from amazon written a second script or a
rewrite of the original that would have
been done around a year ago now i know
that is 100
fact because brad wright has actually
confirmed it to me himself
and we saw the tweet from joseph malozzi
which again actually saw the thing he's
read it he's telling us how excited he
is about it
but does it mean that amazon will go
with that project well i've also told
you a lot over the last few months in
the six months really that there's been
a lot of rumors knocking around mgm that
actually amazon weren't that excited
about brad wright's project and there's
been a lot of discussion about whether
they should move forward with the
original team like maybe brad wright
maybe joseph mosey a few others or
completely start off with a new team and
bring flesh blood into the project
now amazon have complete control over
this they're not even going to allow mgm
to produce the tv series by the looks
even though i'm certainly i'll have
mgm's name all over it when it's
produced it will be produced within
amazon pictures if my source is correct
the source has also confirmed to me
something that was told to me a long
time ago by mgm and mgm sources that
amazon really do consider this to be a
big project and the goal is not just to
create a new tv series but create a
whole new franchise they want to do a
disney plus marvelous kind of project
where we will see tv series movies and
other projects that intertwine with each
other this new source amazon has said
that that is exactly the idea
so how did we get to this point
well it did look like mgm were told
during the sale process that they were
going to be allowed to produce material
as they were before that they were going
to be allowed to continue to almost be a
separate entity from amazon and amazon
would continue to be the customer buying
products from mgm
the meetings in april seem to have
changed that dramatically and the two
top executives of mgm left
this is when things seem to have changed
now there were pitch meetings
there were meetings as well that were
discussing brad wright
there were several meetings about
stargate and other projects amazon
seemed to be assessing where mgm were
but at the end of those meetings the
hammer dropped
this was when amazon then decided and
informed mgm of what the real plan was
only a couple of weeks later the two top
executives resigned or were pushed
the rumor going around mgm and the mgm
offices is that amazon will cherry prick
certain talent from mgm
but then it will be completely absorbed
into amazon pictures and all of the
current offices and things will be just
shifted into other projects or other
parts within the amazon empire
we have to remember that mgm don't
actually own any studios itself and
actually neither do amazon so they will
continue to create projects in the same
way that mg and amazon did in the past
either by renting studio space or
creating projects that are in
cooperation or in partnership with a
third party now this is how a lot of tv
and movies are made at the moment that
won't be anything different
but i really do have to wonder will
stargate be the same once it is dragged
within and underneath the amazon films
and amazon productions umbrella
a lot of the people that have been
working on the project up till now will
probably almost certainly not be
involved now if you don't like some of
the rumors that we've been hearing about
what brad wright had planned for this
new series then you might be quite happy
about this also
in a way there's a lot of positive
things been said by amazon and that they
want to create this to be something a
lot bigger than maybe brad wright's
initial plans um envisaged then and i do
like the idea of movies and series and
things that intertwine with each other
but
i do worry that maybe brad wright will
not go along with this
now if if branch right is contracted to
mgm those contracts will still exist and
will still be enforceable by amazon
amazon now owned them
so
brad wright could easily be involved but
he could easily just as easily not be
so we're gonna have to wait and see here
but how about this idea that amazon will
actually announce this by july 27th
now
my source has said himself that this is
a goal it's an ideal it's what they
would love to do
i asked him but what position are they
at and he again confirmed to me that
lots of the work has been done in theory
this could happen
but it is only in theory it really does
depend on the will of the amazon
executives to whether they really want
to kick start this and especially as
well they don't have to announce this
being green lit they could just announce
that preliminary plans are in place
probably plans that to be honest we
already know are happening they could do
like a pre-green lit green lit
announcement if you like
would i do that by july 27th
the only thing that makes me unsure is
that there is an awful lot of
problems going on with mgm i think
amazon going to want to sort that out
before they really start working any
major projects they also need to maybe
sort out their infrastructure etc as
well to be able to make these projects
so i'm not so sure but hey the room is
out there so if i'm being told it i'll
tell you it
so get in the comments guys tell me what
you think do you think this july 27th
deadline is any sort of possibility or
are we starting to think that maybe this
is six months to a year off which
actually to be fair is what other
sources at mgm that don't work with mgm
sorry that working and around mgm have
suggested to me that actually we're not
going to see anything for at least six
months
which way do you think it'll be i know
what i want but what do you actually
think
and if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit the bell notification
it really helps us out also consider
becoming a fully fledged side tracker
please hit the join button
as always guys please stay safe i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you